keanu reeves may be the internet's
boyfriend but now he's definitely the
internet's favorite person after a tweet
went viral capturing a heartwarming
moment keanu had with a young fan at an
airport yeah we all need more piano at
an airport in our life if you're at the
airport you want to run into him hi
yeah a tv producer named andrew kimmel
captured a photo alongside a long thread
of tweets explaining that keanu was on
his flight from london to new york and
was approached by a young fan at the
baggage claim for an autograph yes and
when that fan began asking keanu a
series of rapid fire questions he
happily responded to every single one as
andrew detailed the kid asked about
everything from keanu's trip to london
over the weekend how long is it going to
be in new york and which broadway show
right which broadway show he was playing
see andrew uh
to our benefit also tweeted out the
exact dialogue which went a little
something like this okay so one of us
got to be the kid one of us gotta be
kanye will you decide uh can it be
why were you in london filming a
documentary
i saw you online you were at the grand
prix yes yes the grand prix f1 race cars
do you do you do you drive not f1 but i
like riding motorcycles actually sounded
very much exactly if you close your eyes
a little bit i kind of sort of like a
little really trying to channel things
some i thought sometimes it felt a
little bill and ted sometimes i felt a
little neo but um i was trying i love
that story i do too that's amazing but
he
hannah reeves has so many great moments
that are i mean we all love him on
camera he's fantastic for what he does
but he has so many more human moments of
connection and and
and caring and kindness that i think you
know he does we only know a few of the
things and places he's donated and think
imagine what he's actually done away
from the camera that we don't know and
one of the things i love about this
whole mystique around keanu reeves is
that people love him
a lot there's a lot of reasons why
people love him one of the main reasons
people love him is because he appears to
be like a normal dude like if you run
into him he'll have a conversation with
you could be polite if you're not polite
he might put you in your place a little
bit but he doesn't appear to put himself
on this level that's completely
different from people and i think for um
any
anyone that's coming up that's going to
become famous
take notes yeah have you interviewed him
i have
i have and he's awesome i've never
interviewed him i haven't interviewed
him yet yeah but and the thing that made
me a little bit nervous about
interviewing him is because i knew that
um
i didn't want to get like wrote
just like wrote answers about this movie
it's keanu reeves i want to talk to
keanu reeves even if i only have like
two minutes on a carpet but he's you
know like
it doesn't feel like he's pretending
things he's really there with you he's
really there so you should also be
present
yeah i like that that's great awesome